حسنًا هنا في مدينة المكسيك هذا الأسبوع
، ولأول مرة ، أعلنت السلطات الصحية
علنًا أنها
حددت حالة
ثبت فيها إصابة المريض ليس فقط بكوفن 19
ولكن أيضًا للأنفلونزا ، هذا المريض مصاب
بهذين
الفيروسين في نفس الوقت
قيل لنا أنه يبلغ من العمر 54
عامًا وله تاريخ طبي يشمل
أمراض المناعة الذاتية
والسمنة وأمراض الرئة المزمنة ،
وتقول السلطات الصحية إن المريض
لا يزال في
المستشفى وهو في حالة مستقرة الآن
لا يعرف الأطباء
بالضبط بعد ما يحدث عندما يكون لديك
كوفن 19 والأنفلونزا
في الوقت نفسه ، لا يزال هذا قيد الدراسة كثيرًا ،
لكن وفقًا
لطب جونز هوبكنز
، يشعر الأطباء بالقلق من أن التأثير الناتج
قد يكون أكثر خطورة
من الإصابة بأي من العدوى وحدها ،
ولهذا السبب
يذهب أطباء السلطات الصحية في المستشفيات.  أن ننظر في حالات
مثل تلك التي أخبرتك عنها للتو عن
كثب خلال الأشهر القادمة بينما
ننتقل
إلى الأنفلونزا ومن خلالها  من
المؤكد أنه
أمر سيقلقون بشأنه في هذه الأثناء هنا في
المكسيك ، يستمر هذا الوباء فقط
مع مئات الأشخاص
يموتون في المتوسط كل يوم نت
جة لفيروس كورونا ، كم
يستمر تسجيل آلاف الحالات الجديدة في ال
توسط.  داي مات ريفرز سي إن إن مكسيكو سيتي